let's talk about a really fascinating
blockchain project called seek Cee K
seek is looking to combine virtual
reality with blockchain and primarily
this would be for the consumption of
live events so concerts for example
through the use of VR their token sale
is over & Seek tokens are already on
major crypto exchanges and right now
what they're getting ready for is the
launch of their first blockchain so to
begin with let's talk a little bit about
the background of the problem that seek
is trying to solve every year 60 million
concert tickets are sold in the US but
it could be a much higher number and
market research shows that demand for
live music events is higher than ever
and musical artists aren't able to meet
all of the demand because artists can
only perform a certain number of
concerts a year a month a week whatever
so they end up having to turn down lots
of people who want to attend and this
also means lost revenue for the artists
and it means that fans are missing out
maybe your favorite artist isn't coming
to your town or the concert that there
is nearby is sold out and seek solution
is to almost infinitely extend the reach
of concerts through the people who want
to use virtual reality to see those
concerts and they're already doing this
seek is a VR company that has been
around for a little while
even before they started tokenizing
their platform they produce a patented
VR headset which can already be bought
at a bunch of different retailers and
they develop VR software including an
app for Android and for iOS which you
can use with other VR headsets not just
the one that they make and they also do
VR content you're already able to use
that app to watch concerts in virtual
reality people like Elton John Katy
Perry lady get Lady Gaga even Megadeth
is part of the platform and actually one
of seeks projects with Megadeth won a
Grammy Award
they've got partnership deals with
Universal Music Group with Apple with
t-mobile so it's a well-established
platform especially compared to some of
the other platforms that have been
tokenizing over the last months or even
year or two
what they're
now doing is building a blockchain
ecosystem on top of the platform that
they already have because they say that
this is going to make for a more user
friendly experience where you're not
having to take off your headset and
leave the VR world to get out your
credit card for example and you can have
that virtual reality experience
uninterrupted seek also is thinking
about this move to tokens from the
transparency perspective at the
transactional level right everything
will be crypto based so it's all
trackable music artists the record
labels the fans everybody knows really
where the money is going and for what
reason under what pretense money is
moving so here's how it works
seek has a mechanism within their
blockchain platform called the celebrity
coin mint artists and music labels use
the celebrity coin Mint to create custom
coins that serve like a ticket to an
event and fans then use those coins for
admission to live VR concerts or VIP
events the meet and greets any kind of
event that a music artist might want to
put on and the celebrity coin mint will
also allow artists and labels to create
virtual merchandise like for example
custom skins that you can use within the
virtual universe of seek other
collectible virtual goods that brands
and music artists might want to
distribute to their fans pretty
limitless possibilities there the idea
is that music artists will only release
a small number of each item so that the
items are rare and could even go up in
value on the market that exists within
the siik platform and each of these
items will have their own aetherium
address on the siik blockchain so each
item is actually unique and certified
authentic which is another reason that
Sikh also wants to tokenize music
artists will even be able to
cryptographically autographed digital
items in the virtual world in a way that
can't be duplicated which also has the
possibility of making those items more
valuable and all of these coins which
against
service tickets for events as well as
for the virtual merchandise it will all
function like crypto within the platform
and people can buy and sell them in VR
like cryptocurrency because again they
all will have unique aetherium addresses
basically everything within what they
call the seek VR environment
entertainment Metaverse is powered by
this blockchain and it's also powered by
the token the seek token is what you use
to buy and sell all of these things that
we're talking about you can actually buy
the seek VR headsets using the tokens
users can also earn seek tokens by
creating lists of music artists that
they want to see perform in VR concerts
which helps the platform figure out
which artists are most in demand you can
also earn seek tokens by sharing a
unique tracking URL on your social media
in order to grow the Sikh community and
they also want to branch out to content
beyond music events I actually spoke to
the CEO and she explained that this
could really be used for anything right
sporting events they already have
partnerships with a few NBA teams yoga
classes medical training taking a
foreign language class anything we're
actually feeling like you're there in
person is important could be used within
the Sikh metaphors so all types of
content creators whether you're a math
tutor or a Grammy Award winning musical
artist you can earn seek tokens by
providing content to the platform
developers developers can earn tokens by
designing those virtual merch items that
I was talking about and by designing
virtual environments within the virtual
world of siik which they call Sikh City
it's kind of like a virtual portal to
all of that VR content and you can earn
tokens by playing an administrative role
within that Sikh city Mary spy o is the
CEO
she holds ten technology patents she's
the former head of satellite
communications at Bo
and is on the advisory board of oculus
VR we interviewed her recently super
interesting interview
Christopher Cramer is a blockchain
engineer cloud computing expert has won
the IBM global entrepreneurs award and
then Laurie Clark is the chief operating
officer a graduate of Harvard Business
School and a former senior VP at Staples
so the big picture here is that seek
offers their own VR headset hardware
that you can buy they're also solving a
huge problem that exists in the VR
industry by offering a platform and
content that can be accessed by an array
of different types of VR headsets and
the problem that I find concerning
within the VR industry is the
fragmentation that exists tons of VR
companies are selling proprietary
hardware here you can buy the headset or
you can use a different headset in many
circumstances you buy a headset you can
only access content designed for that
headset and that stifles everybody
that's titles developers that stifles
the hardware manufacturers seek is
allowing people to access their
ecosystem regardless of which hardware
you are using which I believe will be
productive characteristic for their
progress in the industry but what I see
as most central to the project is how
they are facilitating a solution to two
major problems in the entertainment
industry number one miss revenue
opportunities for performers and
educators I know a ton of these
performers and educators who believe me
folks are missing revenue opportunities
and then also there are consumers that
are missing opportunities to consume
live events whether it's because you
can't afford or get a ticket to a
concert that might be a couple of states
away or on the other side of the planet
or because there's trainings that you'd
like to go to but it's just not
convenient given your work schedule a
lot of consumers will benefit from
having access to these events and it
really could shake up the VR industry if
seek is successful in what they're
trying to accomplish and they're off to
a really great start I encourage you to
check out seek using the link under this
video and of course none of what I've
said is a
financial endorsement or financial
advice of any kind I'm talking about
project this is a tokenized blockchain
crypto project everybody should do their
own due diligence the way that I do and
the way that I advocate that everybody
always do before making any financial
decision